all right ruby
ruby uh where'd you go where are you
from originally
here l.a what part uh
i was born in eastern europe and tell me
about your family you had both your
parents when you're young
i they were my mom was there my dad was
there
i would say
physically he was there but he wasn't
there like
emotionally or he was an alcoholic
how would you describe your childhood
i would say um
people thought it was a family picture
like it was good
well they look like a good family but
like i said my dad was an alcoholic
my mom used to struggle with five kids
um to pay rent to feed us he will leave
um he will get paid on friday and he
won't come back we won't see him till
like monday
check is gone so
i remember a lot of stuff i was uh
molested in elementary i don't know
who did that my teacher teacher
um middleton elementary school
what grade were you i believe i was
a third grader
how did you go in school um i was
i didn't go to school i went all the way
to um high school no
junior high eighth grade but i
i didn't like school i didn't want to go
to school
that was one of the reasons i
you went on your own at what age
what 15.
you went to the streets 15.
yeah i guess you can say i went to the
streets
um
associates
well yeah you can say i went to the
streets
i will come home late at such a young
age
like at two o'clock in the morning
[Music]
at 15 13 14 sometimes i won't even come
home for like weeks
were gangs a part of your life yes
yeah and when did when the drugs come
into the picture for you
i remember taking the first hit of
marijuana
i was about
10 excuse me i have a strawberry sip of
water
10 9 10 but um
uh heroin and cocaine
came a little later like about
i would say 18 19.
i may look a little rough right now i'm
just going through it
i don't know if when the last time i see
how long ago was that
it's probably been four or five months
yeah oh so my mom passed
at that time really she passed um
right after mother's day yeah
it's been since then
sorry about your mom yeah
what is your drug today
excuse me
thank you
uh
heroin
oh [ __ ]
do you have children i do
i do and grandkids
were you able to raise your kids
not as the mother should have known
i mean it's not like they were
taken from me however i was taken from
them
with the streets and the drugs and
everything else
but um
yeah i wasn't a mother to them at all
and who raised your kids excuse me who
raised your
children my mother and my father
my father has been cleaned up for
alcohol
um for like
20 some 30 some years
but it's weird because i mean he's been
through it
but he he wow he judges me a whole lot
but i mean like
i don't get it
and today you're living on skid row in
one of the sros
actually i was lucky um
but it's not healthy
i need to get out of there
yeah somebody um
offering me a place to stay
it's not healthy
what kind of ways have you supported
yourself through the years
well i i did um
a lot of i did prostitution once upon a
time it wasn't my thing
it wasn't something i chose to do but
i mean there's a lot of things you
choose not to do however you're doing
when you're on drugs
um that or
i used to go to the stores or
anywhere i could have boosting boosting
looking back at your life what uh
what what what are your biggest regrets
well for one not being a good daughter
to my mother
and apparent to my kids
do you feel like you were ever loved
excuse me do you feel like you were ever
loved
good question
my mother yeah i could say my mother i
felt that love with my mom
but my father didn't give me that
my brothers and i'm on drugs yeah but
i never went and stole from them or
i always did that [ __ ] on my own by
prostituting myself or
like i said boosting or whatnot
have you ever been in love wow
i i have
however
that was rough because i want
he he i wasn't loving the way that this
person
treated me was with me it was
i don't know it was too good to be true
of course because he got killed
i was pregnant with my daughter and she
never got to see him
so
it was weird because then i i
i wouldn't want to deal with nobody else
but
this one person came by and again that
person got killed so
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
do you feel sometimes like you're cursed
tell me about karma
karma karma
karma's a [ __ ] yes
yeah i mean a few things that i'm going
through i feel like
i should be going through because of
things i've done
karma's a [ __ ]
you wonder if maybe you're paying a
price for things that you're
maybe your dad did or or people
before him it's almost like a
generational curse
i i didn't know my grandpa them too well
but um
he was another alcoholic
till the day he died
and he actually lived quite a long time
for being an alcoholic
i would go with he used to live in
mexico
i would my we would go over there i
maybe went over like once
twice and
i don't know they have different i don't
know weird
believes or i don't know what what do
you call it but um
i will remember situations where
we would be in his ranch or whatever you
want to call it um
he will get a stick off the tree a
branch and he'd be like watch just see
what i'm gonna do right now you're gonna
i'm like well i'll be watching he'll get
a knife and start peeling
the long leaves that will be sticking
out
and then all of a sudden he starts
whooping me with it like that's what the
that's what i'm supposed to see he's i
don't know it was weird
holy [ __ ]
do you feel sometimes like life is
unfair
i feel sometimes like what that life is
unfair
but then again
[Music]
i don't know
it's what you make it really but it's
kind of difficult at times
because
it's easier said than done
[Music]
you feel like there was something in
your childhood or in your past that kind
of set you on this path
of living living like you do and being
addicted
um
it's funny because i mean it's
once upon a time i told myself i i it's
to not i don't want to feel like i'm
gonna just do this and then
leave it alone i don't want to feel this
or but
there's no such thing
like everything just gets worse
have you been clean from heroin
oh yeah when i used to go to prison and
sometimes not even there i will use in
there too
dear friends
do i have friends
well
my one girlfriend is gone my mother
but um
um i guess you could say i do have
friends
but they don't live over or they don't
use drugs
they're
at home or pros i don't know what
they're doing but
my sister-in-law my brother's wife
i can call her my friend
what was the best time of your life
um
when i was with my daughter's father
[Music]
and he passed away yeah he got shot
that's who i was talking about that i
was in love with yeah
yeah he got killed
well he got robbed but to rob him they
had to get him
what emotions do you deal with most now
how many why
what emotions do you deal with most in
your life now
what emotions do i deal with most i mean
do you get depressed do you get anxious
do you get
angry i think
depression that's why i get high
you think you'll be down here the rest
of your life
can't i hope not but i can't call it
i'll probably walk out and
drop dead i don't know
i hope not
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
[Music]
give people the benefit of the doubt
they're not not everybody's the same but
i mean some people do have good
qualities and
have your best interests at heart
not everybody's out to get you but
like then again don't know
i don't know maybe
i don't know [ __ ]
may sound crazy but sometimes i i just
feel like taking myself
out and just get it done and over with
is hope difficult to find sometimes for
you
at times
now time
it turns out
all right ruby thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you thank you
thank you
you